bills i love cereal i love it so tasty
but most of it's full of sugar it's not
healthy but i'll tell you what this one
is
magic spoon yeah magic spoon is zero
grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams of protein
and only four net grams of carb in each
serving
and only 140 calories so guys go to
magicspoon.com forward slash onion to
grab a variety pack and try it today
and be sure to use our promo code onion
at checkout to save
five dollars off your order and
magicspoon is so confident in their
product it's packed with a hundred
percent happiness guarantee
so if you don't like it for any reason
they'll refund your money no questions
asked remember get your next
delicious bowl of guilt-free cereal at
magicspoon.com and use the code onion to
save five dollars off
thank you magic spoon for sponsoring
this episode
harmonize with me and hold me tight all
through the night
you're shining bright i'm your host the
baby you're my pearl
wow well here we are hey
hey we happy three huh
it's amazing right it is when was last
time we were all in a room together do
you want to introduce who it is first
because this could be
audio only yeah yeah it's me dominant
manager
and me billy boyd and hello hi
elijah wood here guys we're giving you
what you want
we considered that if we were to have a
guest
got to start with number one on the call
sheet
frodo yeah the ring bearer and i think
at this point
we kind of broke the mold a little bit
because where do you go from here
i mean well you can't gandalf we're at
the top i mean it's all about
this is it you know it's uh
it's a show where obviously we're going
to talk we talk about lord of the rings
quite a lot
so i mean in that situation
outside of your good self yeah the
person
who we shared the most stories with
in new zealand was and arguably time as
well
yeah yeah um we're close we're very
close
but when was the last time we were all
in the same room together it's a while
ago guys it's been a really long time
we've had we've had a worldwide
pandarus yes that occurred yeah it's
been terrible i think it's been
since the three of us were in the same
room
has it been was it the vigo thing has it
been like eight years
i think it may have been the vega yes oh
then that wasn't eight years that's
that's five six years five years ago
four years ago
i don't know maybe i think it was it was
captain fantastic captain fantastic
that was a good that's crazy we did we
did that zoom
thing for with josh gad that's right
that's a fun thing reunited together
that's right where everyone fit into
their roles perfectly
including orlando who for the entire
time had a low battery on his ipad so it
was constantly
and then he'd mute himself and he'd be
like
didn't he switch devices devices yeah
classic and sean asked him to organize
assistant
yeah two assistants during and mckellen
he signs on smoking a cigarette and
drinking a glass of wine brilliantly not
oh there they all i was very gandalf in
when you showed up
let me look at you hubby happy happy
summer
that was fun that was great yeah that
was an amazing moment
in the whole covert experience for me
because i've had
little pockets of social time with
friends and family and bills and
league of legends and all this kind of
stuff oh yeah but there was what
how many people on that zoom 20 not
quite
15 maybe uh 10 maybe
yeah really there was a lot there was a
there was a lot of people
maybe it was 15 maybe because we had
extra we had carlo bannon miranda and
kate yeah
yeah yeah no you're right phil and
that was pretty incredible amazing so
how has your
comfort time been has it been quiet
uh it's been good i mean as good as
a global pandemic can be um
you know i have a i have a son of a 20
month year old son so
wow the the silver lining of
of this last year and change has just
been watching him grow
you know it's been almost like a kind of
extended parental leave
in a way that we may not ever have this
kind of
uninterrupted time again so that has
been great um
and then i worked on a film i actually
made a movie last year which is crazy
well done yeah in september um did a
commercial like did a little weirdly did
a little bit of work
towards the latter part of last year
right um
which felt kind of wild initially like
getting on a plane the first time
flew to ukraine for for some for a job
and
that felt so strange yeah to have been
really truly isolated you know we were
essentially at our house we'd go to the
grocery store and sort of basic
things but you know there was no other
travel so to get on a plane felt
really wild i bet i mean i'd know that a
lot of
parents with young children have said
even though the challenges of
covid are real for everyone that like
you said they'll never get that time
again
they might not have known if they were
to have had that time
the two of them might have been working
you work internationally so you could
have missed
three or four months of virgil's life
sure so what an incredible experience
that must have been that was awesome
and we you know we didn't have we don't
have
adolescents or kids that are in school
so that made it easier as well i think
the burden of
of the last year for for parents that
have kids that are in school age and
older
you know they have to navigate kids
being separated from friends
having to deal with zoom schooling we
didn't have any of that so it was
relatively simple and he won't remember
any of it which is nice as well
you know i mean you had that more didn't
you bills yeah because i've got a son
who's 15. and we keep telling kids don't
we
we keep saying less screen time you know
not so much screen time
and then we told them you're now at
school
in front of a screen i know all day i
know
and you know i think my son did
amazingly well
but so difficult you know and and
you're trying to kind of make it work
but
it's so hard to concentrate on something
yeah on a screen
and then for the teachers it's so
difficult because the kids don't want
their camera on because of teenagers and
they don't want to
you know have their face there the whole
time when you're just trying to figure
out who you
are and yeah you know so it's so much
easier just to switch the screen off but
then the teachers are looking at
20 black screens and they're like is
anyone there
it was just incredibly difficult and
you've got to applaud
the education and system for
you know managing to get through it and
and really applaud the kids
for getting through it but well let's
applaud the kids yes
well done kids across the world and then
kind of like an actor getting a job
when my son they said we're back at
school
he was like oh yes and he's back at
school and within two weeks he's like
maybe take today off you know like an
actor getting a job and the first thing
you do is you see when's my days off
yes yes haven't worked for six months oh
true you look at the schedule and you
work out
when i've got long weekends oh great
i've only got one scene that day i'll be
finished by one
yeah wishing you days away and then you
just go back to the hotel and order
chicken wings
and watch jerry springer like you've
made a great
choice in your day oh my god that's
funny i tell you what bills living in
this la sun and all the activity that we
get up to i can get dehydrated
it's easy to get dehydrated um what do
you do to combat that i tell you what i
do
i use liquid iv i do exactly the same
and the great thing about liquid iv is
it comes in so many different flavors
lemon lime
acai berry passion fruit guava
watermelon my favorite apple pie
strawberry do you have a favorite oh
strawberry
watermelon's good as well it's also two
to three times
better to be hydrated with liquid iv
than just water
and it contains five essential vitamins
wow so get liquid iv in bulk nationwide
at costco
or you can get 25 off when you go to
liquidive.com
and use the code onion at checkout
that's 25
of anything you order wow when you get
better hydration today
using promo code onion at liquid iv.com
i love cereal bills how about you i love
it dom
i found out that most cereal is kind of
full of sugar and not that good for you
too much sugar you know the solution to
that i do magic spoon
mmm magic spoon because it's zero grams
sugar 13 to 14 grams of protein
and only four net grams of carbs in each
serving and only 140 calories
are serving is that right it's also keto
friendly gluten free
grain free soy free low carb and gmo
free
and so delicious storm cocoa fruity
frosted and my personal favorite peanut
butter oh yeah that's a good one so go
to magicspoon.com forward slash onion to
grab a variety pack and try it today and
be sure to use our promo code onion
and you get to save five dollars at
checkout and magicspoon is so
confident in their product it's backed
with a hundred percent
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason
they'll refund your money no questions
asked that's lovely so remember get your
next delicious bowl of guilt-free cereal
at magicspoon.com
onion and use the code onion to save
five dollars off
thank you magic spoon for sponsoring
this episode
cereal well let me ask you guys this as
as a new dad yeah and as a
dad a better dad a veteran dad of a 15
year old son
what's the most surprising thing about
being a parent
the thing that makes you go wow i did
not realize that
being only 20 months in there's there's
still surprises yet to come i think
uh but i would say i think what
was the most surprising initially was
how quickly
your your body and your mind
becomes a parent how it's sort of an
overnight thing
you you you think about it for a long
time
it's somewhat abstract before you're an
actual parent so in the nine months
leading up to the birth of your
child there's all there's classes that
we took there's a lot
of prep and thinking about how that's
going to be
and making sure you have all of the
tools that you need
specifically for that first few months
and then the baby's born
and you're like oh yeah i know what i'm
doing somehow
the instinct kind of just kicks in and
your reality is
that's my child right it's that kind of
blew my mind yeah how fast that happened
and that first sort of eight weeks
i remember because it's it was wonderful
and weird and crazy because you know
if you read books on it and you can read
one book that will tell you exactly one
thing
and you can get another book that will
tell you that absolutely opposite yeah
so you can
you can read as much as you want but
you've just got to work it out
and that first eight weeks they're not
you're basically just looking after them
because they don't know
that you're any different from a chair
you know it's just like
sure you know it's my world as far as a
baby's concerned and
you know so you're just looking after it
and then when they start to notice you
and then you know and it's so weird and
wonderful
yeah but i i remember that that first
eight weeks when i was reading all the
books and i thought i'm just forgetting
about this
yeah and the moment for me when i
thought i'm just forgetting all this and
doing it the way
i think it should be done was my
favorite thing
was to fall asleep on the couch with
jack on my chest yeah
and then i read a book that said don't
do that and i thought i'm done with this
i've done my books i absolutely love
that yeah what was their justification
they were scared that you were going to
like
roll over and like lie on them and kill
them or something
but you're like and then you read
another book that said you would never
do that because
right in some place in your brain you
know that there's a baby
that's right and another book saying you
should roll over on your child
to keep them thin and kind of
streamlined
keep them protected from the elements
but i love that because you're so tired
right because you're getting up at all
sorts of times and
and really the mother's doing everything
but you want to feel like you're part of
it
so you stay awake well she's feeding
them or whatever or
but um you're just exhausted and
just that you know it's it's good enough
falling asleep on the couch
and just kind of dozing off but with a
baby
oh my god i love that i miss that oh
yeah because at a certain point they
don't want to sleep with you
yes and like it used to be that he would
wake up in the morning we'd put him back
in bed and he'd go back to sleep and
we'd go back to sleep it's great
yeah that is so over now but that that
first
eight weeks is magical i have real i
have real
uh i've really romanticized that period
in my head because it is like
you're you're in and out of sleep the
baby sleeps
every couple of hours feeds every couple
of hours
and so you're just sort of in this weird
haze of like
sleepiness and feeding and you know
getting getting meta-marie food well
you know so your job as a father is just
like to make sure that
she's taken care of and the baby's
taking care of you're not doing the
breastfeeding but you you are a part of
that cycle
yeah which is so lovely so we we got a
thing because
my wife breast fed as well that we got a
thing that she would pump
for one of the feeds and then she'd have
a lion and this was about
five six in the morning and i'd take the
dog
my old dog griffin oh yeah we we go for
a walk in the park with me and jack
and i would feed him from the bottle
while griffin ran around
and the sun was coming up and then ally
could get asleep you know
and my other friend paul riley who you
know was making a new sitcom
and he tells me on this day that they'd
set up a camera
on the hill i didn't know this at the
time
on the hill in this park they'd set up a
time lapse
so that they could watch the sun coming
up for the start of this
sitcom yeah i'm at that hill
with jack and the dog the dog starts
chasing some um birds around
and there's a woman who look kind of
scared you know so i'm shouting on the
dog
and i went and walked and i slipped down
the hill with
with jack like this one
and i'm rolling down the hill to get
griffin and
that day paul tells me we've got a
camera set up before i'd told him that
story
and i was like you've got to have a look
at the footage and see if you see me
rolling down the hill
but he never saw it oh no way what's the
chat too fast
all the things you do you make it work
in that first little way
oh yeah i remember coming to see you in
glasgow
when jack was relatively young and you
you telling me like i'm doing this thing
in the morning where
we give ali an extra hour and a half
sleep we can go
walk around the park wait until the
coffee shops open up
get a coffee walk the dog and even at
that point in my life i wasn't
quite getting up as early as i do now
but i still did it and then i remember
this is kind of a slightly disgusting
story but i'll tell it anyway
hey we so we did that we went and got
coffee i wasn't really drinking coffee
at the time we got coffee
walked the dog and you were like okay
i'm gonna go back and check in on ali
and i said all right i'm just gonna walk
around the park a little bit and i was
coming down with a cold
or something like that and i produced
the largest what would you call it
flame ball yeah i guess flembo
yeah lugi from from my um
breathing systems that i've ever
produced in my life
i didn't have my phone on me but i
remember thinking that is
photo worthy it was massive
and did you just leave that in glasgow
just left it it was just on
the wet rain-soaked streets of glasgow
but i remember thinking that's
extraordinary that that's been inside me
just sat around yeah
and and i felt fantastic that they'd
come out yeah i bet you did
now you've been to glasgow as well i
have yeah you came from my wedding
certainly did that was very kind of you
that was really fun that was lovely and
we had a lovely time it was new year was
it was it was
and then we went for some nice
restaurants and you came in my wedding
we had uh
some really good indian food if i
remember correctly oh the indian food
was good
yeah and where where i stayed in
glasgow's great indian restaurants
that's a lovely neighborhood yeah it's a
great wedding it's a great wedding
lots of people up and dancing at that
wedding there was
included me you were a dancer queen was
dancing all night
from from what i can remember and then
we carried on after that
yeah we went to we went to ireland oh
that's right
we we flew with jason to um
we went to galway we went to goal we
went to kill kenny we were in ring of
carry we didn't go to court we went to
ring of carry our friend jason limerick
we were in liberty
our friend jason basically kind of
slipped a disk didn't he
he has he had and has back issues anyway
but yeah i think he did about about a
day or two into the trip
no do you know how he slipped a disc how
did he do it dancing because
you guys if you remember i rented you
guys an apartment
near where oh yeah that place was great
it was a great rooftop apartment
but it didn't have enough beds so i put
an uh
a futon for one of you guys to sleep on
you know a kind of japanese full
stone bed and to get it back to my house
jason said i'll help you and you guys
were at the top
of an old tournament building oh yeah
and i said you know what we could just
throw it off
the inside of the stairway oh sure
yeah and make sure no one's coming in
and jason
threw it over but when he threw over the
balcony
his desk went out and his back went
and that was it did you not tell me
he was in a wheelchair it was he was he
was in a wheelchair getting off the
flight so he got on the plane all right
obviously he didn't need a wheelchair to
get on the plane he sat on the plane
and then you know with any back issues
if you're if you're sat sedentary for a
long time
and you don't stretch it gets worse and
then when he stood up he couldn't
he couldn't walk and they got him a
wheelchair and we
we were waiting for him and baggage
claim
he's like the last person off the plane
it gets
wheeled out yeah and elijah and i
very uncharitable sorry jason we're
laughing quite a lot
oh my god jason's going in a wheelchair
and he was like don't make me laugh
don't be
poor guy i got
sick on that trip i had a really bad
cold and i feel like you were coming
down with something as well
because remember the snot story from
earlier on that would have only been
that would be a few days
and i remember what's the um what's the
really great
cold medicine that has uh codeine in it
oh is it benellin
benadryl benadryl no i think benellin's
benellin
i think benalin is english it's not
because it's not
we don't have nyquil and dayquil no it
was like a oh but it was like
it was like a headache medicine but with
codeine i feel like it's better
that really that sorted me out well
that's sazirip that's what little
wayne's into right scissor but this is
pills these were
these were pills he drinks the syrup
yeah and then wraps
he's an extraordinary rapper but his
wrapping
comes from codeine well it's just
inspired by code isn't there a there's
an entire genre
that that that goes along with scissor
that's like a slowed down yeah wow
that's like slowed down beats that they
listen to because of the
i'm pretty sure we should sound a little
ignorant now i can't
oh elijah you never sound no no no don't
say that about yourself
we should talk music though because
music is such
a formative bonding thing for us
not only is billy in a band and has you
know created a bunch of
albums and songs but the three of us
are all massive music fans and our
experience
in new zealand in so many ways was
collared by music
oh yeah absolutely a lot of time at real
groovy
and if we go back into that time we're
in the cd
world oh god yeah so what you're
actually expected
or you need to go and buy a physical
copy
now if we were doing lord rings the
three of us would sit home on our
computer and just download the music and
it wouldn't be the same
community thing because when we went to
real groovy records you'd be walking
around saying to me
oh you should pick up this this prince
bootleg thing and i'd say to you
well have you seen this and you go oh
you have seen that but you should get
the second album yeah we're constantly
sharing your information
we spent so many hours in that store so
many more
so well it was per diem wasn't it yeah
and for anyone who doesn't know
per diem uh when you when you live away
from home
making a tv or film uh you get a
per diem to help you
of course four per day exactly dominate
wonderful
the old latin's coming back from school
yeah now
and and you're meant to use it for
buying your dinner
or living expenses living expenses and
we would
spend all on the friday at real groovy
yeah buying music yeah that we would
then listen to
in the makeup trailer all that week we'd
take days each
you know that would uh be elijah on the
monday and he'd say oh have you heard
this album
yeah and then the tuesday dawn would say
have you heard this and
we were such a big part of our life huge
part we would
love sean astin as we do we would tend
to skip
sean astin's musical um
i mean because i don't know that shawn
ever contributed well i think he had
one day where he did it and from what i
would have been like billy joel it was
billy joel's greatest hits no it was it
was really joel's greatest hits
and i love an uptown girl hey wow but
over and over again piano man
yeah piano man but he's a little penis
didn't he yeah
really sure um if if i mean we could go
on and on about music forever
yeah but if you were to
have one album that you would pick
to define that lord of the rings
experience because i do i've thought
about this
and i'll i'll i'll kick it off oh lovely
that sounded like an effect from lords
do that again
that's what i do when i think i sound
like well you probably haven't heard
that that much
look see elijah does it no anytime i'm
hearing that i'm thinking that you've
got coffee on the go but that's you
thinking that's me thinking
wow that's the thinking sound yeah i've
got two albums but i won't say them yet
go
i'll kick it's only allowed one well
let's can we condense it down to what
we can do no no i'll do one you could
have an a side and a b
side no it's a cd very tricky i i
started to make a list
uh for the q a that we did
the the hobbit q a that we did with
stephen colbert
so one of the things that i thought
might come up would be music to discuss
and so i made a huge list of all of the
music that we were listening to at the
time but to pick
a single album because we were also
djing
quite a lot of it so there's there's a
lot of the classic
stuff the bangers that we would dj
and then we'd have the stuff that would
wake us up in the morning
and then we'd have the the euphoria of
rapping
and stuff like that but if i'm if i'm
gonna kick it off
so many albums so many things that we
listen to but if
if i think about one album that sims it
all down it's probably the men who
by travis nice
good one because that went through the
entire principle photography it never
fell off
never did we were all singing it a lot
always we all loved it i remember when
you and i
were looking at apartments in wellington
we hadn't had one yet
we hadn't chose one yet well maybe we
were
we were humming the guitar part right up
the stairwell all right
yeah i remember in fact i think you did
have an apartment i think it was changed
it was your apartment building was it i
think so and elijah and i from what i
recall was stood waiting for
a lift or an elevator
and we started humming the guitar was it
the guitar track from
turn i think i think so and we did like
the halls
that is so specific we did have albums
over over that time period that we loved
for a while
and then not that we started to dislike
them but you
you reach a peak with those like macy
gray is a good example we all love that
first album i tried to say goodbye
and that joke but then it got to a point
where we were like okay we're kind of
done with it it was also in
every shopping mall everywhere it's huge
i love that album i just rediscovered
that again
oh because i was thinking about the
music but that's you've done two albums
tom
no no i just mentioned one the man who
travis that's your
that's my one do you want me to go or do
you want to go elijah
that's your thinking yeah right here's
mine
and it's actually from a specific time
and in our sort of um can we guess it if
you give us the time
no no [ __ ] all right then maybe okay i
will
i'll give you the time and i'll tell you
why it's stuck in my head
it was when we were in
queenstown and the drive to set
was basically the length of this album
so we listened to it every day
on that drive what was that album
i have a guess elijah you go first um
was it was it the wilco record was it no
hotel foxtrot good that's good
good uh thought but yeah no because that
was big that was good that was a big one
yeah
my guess yep parachutes coldplay nailed
it i've done it
well what an extraordinary album that
was a great album
yeah yeah i mean if we oh lars you've
not done yours yet
um i actually just pulled up the list no
oh he's
gone into the octagon it twice
hold on hold on everybody i mean and
it's not necessarily the one that you
like the most it's the one that
defines the lord the reason software
slump granddaddy oh yeah on an album
in terms of that that particular
criteria it
it permeates the experience that was one
of those things that we discovered and
just like
oh man kept going back to it but there
are so many others but that one
and that is interesting because not only
in that time are we discovering bands
like
travis and coldplay and software doves
were big as well
doves yeah wilco but there was also
stuff
in all of our back catalogues so you had
been bringing
prince songs that no one had heard right
and i was bringing beetle stuff and you
were bringing radiohead stuff and we
wrote down roses
roses morphing into each other yeah
eminem
was a big deal for us yes yeah and your
12-inch mix tape so your mixtape of
your 12-inch records had
young mc on it yeah the know-how 12-inch
yeah
it had the 12-inch of i could never take
the place of your man by prince
so good some like crazy outcast stuff
and stone brothers
hate 12 inches is a big one for me
that looms large because we used to
listen to that all the time on road
trips
and you know i'm sure you guys know
about this
but the reason why we listened to so
much music was because we had to spend
what started out as being about two
hours and ended up being
i think an hour and a half hour 40. yeah
we started out more
as i remember it was from being picked
up
to being ready it was three hours right
so if it was a half seven start
we'd be picked up at half four so
you know it was a long time it was a
long time so there was a couple of
albums you could listen to at least
yeah it's so crazy thinking about that
and the length of time that it took that
when they moved when they
when they got to the hobbit the feet
were pull on wow
they were they were shoes and perfect
like beautiful
silicon they weren't using latex anymore
wig lace was already punched in it was
absolutely all done you pulled it and it
went up to your ankle
or up to your knee yeah and they were
just so
shoes standing on those bodies standing
and getting things
glued to your feet glued to your feet
but also as i'm sure you guys
remember with all the chemicals every so
often
we might get a little tiny nick
yeah an open little cut on our feet
and then they're applying glue and
alcohol and chemicals to it and it would
get sore and infected and sting and then
the next day they'd have to do it again
and yeah
and i don't know if you wanted to he had
the most
emergencies i had i had
had a varuka on my foot which is
verruca now avaruka uh here would be
a planter what i think it's called
is it okay i don't know a wart i can
answer this
oh hold on i can answer dominic here on
my rachel hello hello
a veruca is essentially and i'm sorry to
say this billy
a wart that you've applied
pressure onto which i can't help because
i'm walking
so let's yeah let's say you've gone
let's say you've got one of those
yeah no good point you could have hopped
let's let's say you've got one of those
witch's warts you know like with a tuft
of wiry hair coming out yeah right
those things are 3d because there's not
physical pressure on them sure
but on the base of your foot because
you're putting body pressure constantly
the wall
goes in an inverted wall
so it's basically a hole at the bottom
of your foot
and i'm sure it's called a palanteer or
something in america isn't that that
thing that you stole from
me yeah you're living in the lord of the
rings trilogy
i don't know if that's right i'm doing
some surreal
it's nice now let's find out we have the
technology but a veruca
is it's an ugly thing of a disgusting
walk
and i apologize to anybody out there
dealing with ferruccus at the moment
but if you have to wear hobbit feet
every
day you will never get rid of a varuca
i'll tell you that
because the people who used to deal with
the feet would sometimes
over the year and a half apply veruca
ointment to trying but because it's
covered in a latex
foot all day you've got no no have you
brought up
looked it up it's not nice is it called
the plantain no just
like i just see veruca very very common
if you attend public swimming baths
which is probably where you got it
dirty dirty man you're going to watch
what you're walking always wear
flip-flops
if you're in the swimming pool that's
why i don't know if you
i don't know how often you attend public
swimming paths elijah because you know
i've been frodo i i've been to one okay
in new york the um
the turkish russian baths and i don't
know where this is gonna go
ladies and gentlemen i don't know
they're great it's great so you know you
have that little
kind of disinfectant walkway yeah you
come out of the showers and then there's
a little kind of just
that's just often like wood or something
like that is to try
and stop curb verruco the veruca
community
and i can't remember good name for a
band actually
and they're it's called uh it's called
the verrucka pool
and it's there is a latin for it which i
can't remember
but um for ten points name a character
in any well-known movie
with the name veruca veruca bam
yeah well done who is ten points she was
a name she was in uh willy wonka in the
chocolate factory
she's the one that uh she
um she's the bad egg she says i want it
now the song
yeah i want the world i want the whole
world i want to give it to me
now right that's her supposedly i heard
that the uh limp and
then fall into a forward roll thing that
gene wilder did was improvised i heard
that too
yeah he had he told the director he was
going to do it but they didn't tell any
of the kids
oh that's him just to have that kind of
perspective oh that's so cool
i love that film well that was feat that
was a whole
conversation about hobbit feet yeah
virtually just
touched on it i mean we could keep going
because we've not even mentioned the
fact that sean astin kept a list of how
many times he put on his feet in the
word featured i don't know what he was
hoping to do that sounds like something
that yeah
you know what else well no what he also
did on his mirror
uh sorry to call you out sean but when
we went back for pickups
he put the he drew a calendar on the
mirror
and would slash out the days well
do you remember that i don't really yeah
i can't remember if it was this
it may have been one of the the second
or third time we went for pickup so
taking all your days off just kind of
taking the days
no i mean i mean i think you know it's
it was
i think it was a little different for
sean too coming back and
you know older family man like sure you
know
the sort of his reasons for that were
probably different though we're all on
our own different journeys
i um i i i asked billy this and i'll ask
you again like because i'm so confused
about this thing
i always thought that the four of us
kept a diary whilst we were putting on
our
hair and feet and wigs and billy said no
that was just i
you did yeah i had a journal
that i started and i have it in my room
here
i i just didn't keep up with it i've i
my entire life i've been really bad
about
journaling uh for me it's mainly been
photography has been my way of kind of
holding on to memories and capturing
moments in time but sitting down and
writing has never been
never i've never stuck with it and i've
always wanted to and to a degree i've
sort of regretted
not keeping one but i did i did briefly
try talking about so yeah you're not
wrong
yeah did you not lose a lot of your
photographs
i remember years ago your sister or
someone getting in touch with me
saying elijah has his computer hard
drive has gone and his other hard
drive's gone and he's lost
basically all his photographs from new
zealand yeah and
you know did i have any and i couldn't
find mine either i don't know where mine
are
yeah so that's interesting there must be
a ton of photographs somewhere
well thankfully most of the photographs
that i took while we were shooting
were analog they were mostly actual
films
film photos so i have all of that good
and then we all got digital cameras sort
of towards the tail end of it
right yeah i don't have any of those
photos i don't think
yeah i had my laptop stolen as well and
i did you yeah
so did i yeah crazy right yeah and i
lost a lot of
photos but you remember when the three
of us such a gut punch man oh it's
horrible it's soul-destroying it really
is it completely changed the way that i
felt
about the medium i just thought well if
you can lose
photos after all that work and all that
investment i don't know if i have the
heart to do it again it was really
heartbreaking yeah
but do you remember the three of us went
to auckland on a little weekend trip
together
and i have all those photos i have all
those and i have it in a photo library
and for some reason
i think it was me but we there's a lot
of
um overly posed photos of like you guys
yes oh yeah or like holding an unlit
cigar
or pointing at a seagull yeah there's a
lot of those
i'll bring that in one day yeah and that
was also during um
what's the the the the boat race that
they
the americas caught yeah it was during
america's cup that we were right
so i don't know that we engaged with it
but i do remember that was happening in
the background of our trip
i seem to remember being on an america's
cup boat
with you the louis vuitton as i remember
it
yeah i don't know if it was that year
okay
but um yeah we definitely did that so we
got a sort of
ringside seat of the america's cup
and which was all for free and they took
care of us and everything but i remember
the cost
of that for getting on the boat and
being able to drink champagne and
you know eat those fancy sandwiches
was a few kind of posh-o people
kind of dealing with those like
curiosities a little bit like oh look
at those people over there oh come take
pictures with us come take pictures with
us
oh i hear you guys orbits and i remember
thinking oh is this the cost for the
and you're awesome it's worth it for the
free shipping absolutely
absolutely delicious
we've had some questions as you always
do from um
from the great outdoors should we jump
into that because we could treat you
forever
yeah we're gonna do the first one it's
from
matilda sophie from or is that her name
strange yeah
or is that a place in denmark no i think
that you might know this
that's the full name okay so it's
matilda
sophie strunj from denmark lovely
she asks or he asks matildy it's a it's
a woman yeah
she asks have you read other tolkien
books beyond the lord of the rings the
hobbit
the silmarillion or farmer gals of ham
if so
what did you think about them great
question
yes i've only ever read the hobbit of
of the other materials yeah i've not
read this
it was a round wasn't it it was yeah
rings but i've not read it and i
remember asking
i have it philippa boyens uh pete and
friends
writer i said is it worth reading the
silmarillion she said it's fantastic
it might not necessarily help you in
lord the rings but she said it tells
the story of men and dwarves and elves
and stuff
but it's quite dense yeah it
apparently reads more like a history
book than a novel
right yeah i haven't yeah the hobbit
lord of rings is all i've done
uh well you know what i'm going to read
one of the others
and i don't i think i will do this on
marilyn yeah there you are let me know
here i'd love to read this somewhere
earlier why don't we all read it
together sauron's origins in this film
really
cool isn't that didn't tolkien write one
called something like
untold stories or untold unfinished
tales
unfinished that's supposed to be one of
the more accessible
okay which i think christopher his son
who kind of became the the steward of
the of
his work edited that because i think
it's it is genu
genuinely a compilation of unfinished
works
that he put together and compiled that
would be interesting
maybe we should all do that one if you
guys can hear a distance siren yep
it's not someone playing grand theft
auto 3 close to us
it is actually an emergency i can see it
down there
in the distance it's an ambulance when i
first moved to la
remember you and i hanging out in the
first two or three weeks of me
having moved to l.a yeah you were in
that back i was in converted garage
right right yeah i was extending my old
manager's converted garage which had
no toilet mm-hmm no oven
was there no shower no shower there was
a fridge
and a bed and that was it and she gave
me a tv
and you and i were hanging out one day
and i said i really want to get a dvd
player and you said
well if you're going to get a dvd player
why don't you get a playstation 2.
and i said i don't need a playstation 2
i just need a dvd player and you said
no no no
[Laughter]
a playstation 2 is a dvd player and a
games player
and you know i'm massive on twofers i
love a bargain
yeah so i was like okay i'll get one of
those and then
was it you that loaned me grand theft
auto 3 or was it someone else maybe yeah
it was either you or mac aston yeah you
gave me a couple of other things
and that was my new journey
into the world of gaming right just
based on a happenstance comment from you
where you said
well get a playstation 2. it's it's both
of them yeah crazy
so while we're talking about gaming is
this the perfect time dom
between me and you are we going to pitch
should we pitch
elijah our team yeah let's pitch it what
you do
elijah yeah well you know that through
lockdown billy and i've been playing
this game league of legends oh yeah
which you tried desperately to get me
involved
it's a five-man team we only have four
we have four myself you need a fifth
billy boyd
his young son jack who's a great gamer
and nigel
nigel nelly yeah and we need an extra
person and we've said for months
because your your base level
gaming ability is a lot higher
than most people's because you did grow
up gaming i did yeah
my son jack is really the only gamer
that we have
and he's really good dom has spent more
hours playing
league of legends than anyone else alive
so he's he's half decent you know he's
okay
yeah nigel is slightly better than me
he has five accounts where he kind of
you know
tries to get better than us moonlights
oh yeah and
i am really awful but i just hide in the
jungle
so we need you if we're going to take
this to the next level
yeah and i'd like to go to the next
level i would
because the thing is with league of
legends is because at that point it's a
five-man team with everyone on comms
yeah if you're playing against like
let's say a bunch of individuals and
none of them are on comms yeah you've
already got an advantage because you can
say hey everyone go to the top lane
everyone get a dragon
yeah haven't gone over over here you
would love that game
i know you don't have as much time as
you would like to with
a young child in your life but i know
you love gaming i do yeah
and it is a lot it's free to play yeah
we should be sponsored by these guys
it's free to download it is an
extraordinary game right
need to play it yeah you've got to and
if you were there and we could talk to
each other
then because you can send you send
little kind of signal saying i'm going
here now
or i'm going there or i need help i
can't do any of that elijah
because there's too many buttons to
press yeah i'm i'm just focusing
on not dying yeah in the jungle yeah so
if you were there i could say elijah
come and help me and i wouldn't have to
press any buttons sure
yeah so that would really help us out if
you could do that for us please
i would love to play a game with you
guys yeah i mean even if you download it
for free
yeah and play and play the game for free
after a couple games you go
not really my thing you've not lost
anything at large it's true
you've only gained a deeper
understanding of us really
[Laughter]
it's really fun how often do you guys
play we play
five or six hours a day nah no
not that much is it we play at least
once a week i would say right because
well you know in the world we have like
a regular
yeah in the week we're busy and some of
us might be working but usually at some
point on a saturday or something or a
saturday or a sunday friday night
it can be all getting together and then
you can do everyone get yourself a cup
of tea if you want to glass away and
have a glass of wine yeah we've done
tipsy league of legends have you yeah oh
and then we just
we get on the rift and we really we pick
our characters
and then we really go at it
it's capture the flag it's basically
capture the flag so you're trying to
destroy their base while they're trying
to destroy yours
is there is there a mission that you're
trying to achieve you're trying to
destroy their base how their troops
but like where you are in the game are
you trying to level up is there i don't
really know oh there's all sorts of
things
you're on a map you start on a map on
it's always the same map always the same
map but you can pick different champions
the cool thing about league of legends
is
if you want to be a crazy norwegian
berserker viking guy that throws axes
around you can be if you want to be a
cat
on a magic carpet you can be that too
and everything in between
and all you're trying to do is destroy
their base yeah while they destroy yours
it is some of the most fun i've ever had
in a game there's a couple of games that
we've played that has been
really truly wonderful times
and i know that you're going to be
brilliant at it
and also because of your vibe because
there's a kind of
negative vibe sometimes in in league of
legends where people
will they could look at aggro see
foreign
who's in the jungle and he's a big lad
and he does a lot of damage
he can set himself on fire and you know
he should be making a lot of kills and
not dying much so
i had died eight times and hadn't killed
anyone
and the other person our fifth person
said
how is dr mundo eight and zero
you know eight there's no kill sure and
i said well i'm not very good
i i type back just to let them know and
they said
please never play again
that's a shame isn't that a shame
please never play again that's called
that's called oh my god and i know you
would never take that
down never that's why we need you okay
that's great in the in the community in
the league of legends community that's
called
flaming right oh okay he flamed billy
and you know you've spent more time with
billy and i than almost anyone
billy and i have never really had a
crossword nah
not really we've had debates we've
disagreed about stuff but we've never
had a crossword
we had our first ever official fight
playing league of legends can you
believe that yeah
i hold my hands up it's my phone because
i was not defending the tower
well enough for them oh i watched billy
on a mat
on the map because you can watch what
other bats really funny
the very first the first fight ever and
i had to
have a word in myself and i called billy
the next day and i said i sincerely
apologize
my behavior was a disgrace and he didn't
let me off the hook he went well yeah
that was a disgrace
but what had happened was so you can
watch because you have to go back to the
shop to get items and all those kind of
stuff sure and you can watch what's
going on so as i'm going back to the
shop
i went to see what billy was doing and i
said billy don't he's still angry about
it
i said billy don't don't teleport back
to the shop there you go you're going to
get hit by the enemy
he said no no i'll be fine he got hit by
the enemy oh billy don't
and he went no i've been frozen i've
been i've been hit by one of morgana's
binds
and i went no that's not what happened
and we got into a little step two
nigel our friend nigel's in the middle
of it and he's going hey
guys let's just because he'd never seen
us have a fight
i then had to apologize to billy
throughout the rest of the game which
went on for another 10 15 minutes
the air was you could cut the tension
with a knife and i was going
i'm sorry about that bills i just got a
little excited billy's like well you
know you're kind of a [ __ ] there you
know
kind of being a bit of an [ __ ] and it
was an [ __ ] wow so it can
really go it can get under your head and
the reason why i think that happened
was because we were missing a fifth man
oh god exactly
i would love to prevent that from ever
happening could you please yes
you could and i honestly like i think
you would
love it because it is so much fun but
the only thing
is it's also fun to get your mates
together yeah online and play
it's just fun lightly worried that you
would play for
two weeks and then you would be ranked
and you'd be off playing for a real team
you know that
and i would never leave you would you
that's sweet well that's been recorded
together you know i would never we need
the ring bearer
we need a leader that's what we do that
reminds me
that notion of the two of you having
your first fight ever ever that reminds
me the first time
we had a thing you were it was we were
in queenstown
you were napping your trailer door do
you remember this
well this is this is insane stuff here
folks i don't even
i think your trailer door may have been
opened i'm a deep sleeper
i i came i approached very excited
what was that that's the thing i can't
really remember i know what it was what
was
[Music]
you said [ __ ] off
i think i tried to physically attack you
he came into my trailer
wrapped a
[Applause]
that was amazing you blew up and it
wasn't yeah you didn't have any control
over it you were coming out of a very
deep sleep but man that was funny i was
i was much more cantankerous back in my
lord the rings days
for two reasons go on one i was drinking
more alcohol
which which is associated with a much
poorer sleep
and yeah you know there's probably a
little bit more hangovers involved i
said to bills the other day
not that in any way was i walking around
you know drunk or drinking at work or
anything
i would just enjoy a sunday night drink
yeah so on
monday i'd be a little bit slower than
normal if i could do lord of the rings
trilogy again
the only thing that i would change was
would be to be not hungover on a monday
morning because i think i missed
quite a few amazing moments and as you
guys both know at the weekend
what time would i get out of bed one two
in the afternoon oh yeah yeah
you guys had served had breakfast
sometimes four yeah that was pretty
extraordinary
a lot of days a lot of sleep you were
watching a lot of days lots of david
attenborough
and the best uh goals of man united
yeah on repeat yeah yeah
i would have company yeah you won't get
into that let's go to another question
realize you want to release that on
guzzney street
i was on eggmonster okay yeah but
very close to uh cube street yeah right
around the corner from cubase yeah i was
right in the center of town
sure you know eva dixons has gone i know
we've talked about that oh that's a
shame that was a wonderful
place not only is it gone i went on the
last day
of it being open which one the one near
wetter the one downtown
the one downtown oh man the one upstairs
yeah i just
i was in new zealand in wellington for
some reason eggs benedict was from eva
dixon
brilliant some lovely breakfasts really
laid back spend a long time just hanging
out in there
and i was in new zealand and i thought
i'm going to go to eva dixon's
and there was a poster we closed today
and i went up and i had a coffee and i
was like
but what's the chances that you would
laugh
from my recollection was either dixon's
was the entrance to eva dixon's on a
relative courtney narrow side street
yeah i think so
because i remember having breakfast with
the two of you guys
climate staircases yeah yeah i remember
having breakfast with the two of you
guys and orlando showed up late and he's
like oh my god
i hide a nightmare hey pickle i couldn't
park anywhere there's nowhere apart and
we said where did you party with our
parts
start at the restaurant we were like
that's a narrow one-way street you can't
probably it'll be fine now come get me
if it's a problem and he kept his car
there for like an hour
while he had breakfast just blocked off
the entire stream
wow well isn't that fantastic
isn't he a fascinating man he is so
fascinating in fact that we've got so
much elijah wood
goodness that we're going to cut it
there this week and we'll have some more
elijah next week oh it's going to be
like a double album oh yeah
brilliant with a full doubt brilliant
so yeah more elijah wood next week